let's bring in michigan republican
congresswoman lisa mclean a member of
the house armed services committee and
the house education and labor committee
it's not just texas where these folks
are being released we talked about it
last night on the fox report charter
flights are are bringing uh illegal
aliens to airports all over the country
they're releasing them in the middle of
the night and letting them go who knows
where because the the federal government
isn't telling us the administration
isn't telling us
what do you say to that congresswoman
i say it's an embarrassment i say shame
on president biden
and when is this administration going to
start putting the american people first
what's happening down at our southern
border is absolutely unbelievable yet
our northern border we're locked down
and everyone's got to get a covid test
and you have to show your id to make
sure that your code that you are who you
are when you have your cova test
i wonder if that's going on at the
southern border i can assure you it's
not
what you've seen is actually 100 true
i've been down to the border twice i've
been to colombia i've been to panama and
exactly what is happening is it's
unbelievable
this administration has an open for
business sign at our southern border
don't worry about covid don't worry
about vetting who's coming over don't
worry about the amount of fentanyl and
illegal drugs that are coming over
yet what is going on with law and order
in our country
we are asking
these law enforcement officers these
border patrol agents that have given
their life to protecting our border
we're asking law enforcement agents not
to enforce the law this is exactly what
happens when you let joe biden and his
and his socialist administration run
this country and it's about time that
the american people stand up and know
what's going on what's so bad about
telling the people the truth
yeah why do you have to hide it why do
you have to do it in the middle of the
night you do it because you know it's
wrong and you know you don't want anyone
to find out
president biden shame on you my orcas
and shame on this entire administration
for not putting the american people
first like they deserve
alejandro mayorkas the secretary of uh
homeland security had that meeting with
border patrol agents and here's part of
the transcript of the meeting as
obtained by town hall the job he says
has not gotten any easier over the last
few months and it was very very
difficult throughout 2021 i know the
policies of this administration are not
particularly popular with u.s customs
and border protection but that's the
reality and let's see what we can do
within that framework so he's asking the
people who work for him to willingly
look the other way and ignore the laws
because that's what the president
apparently wants to do
yeah
and think of that for for one moment if
he needs some help on what to do i can
give him a few ideas let me start with
one finish the wall because like it or
not it worked because the crate there's
a crazy thing do you know where the
illegal immigrants are coming through
they're coming through holes where the
wall isn't completed so obviously the
wall works implement catch and release
and shut the southern border down i'm
imploring this administration
please put the american people first
because this isn't a southern border
issue
these people are getting released into
the interior of our communities
felons
prisoners we have no idea no one's
vetting these people they are releasing
them into communities and the other
thing that's happening is all the
fentanyl is coming through yeah we have
stripped these law enforcement agents of
all of their duties and we have
relinquished them to just being
processors and administrators when they
need to be on that border securing our
our borders for the american people
period fentanyl deaths hitting a record
in this country right now i want to
quickly put up the numbers that show uh
the the scope of the problem in november
of 2020 we had 72 000 uh illegal
apprehended
illegals apprehended at the southern
border uh 2021
173 000 more than a hundred thousand
more and then look at december 178 000
uh in 2021 as compared with 73 000 just
one year ago you can't sustain those
kinds of numbers and still have a
country congresswoman
we can't and i can't for the life of me
understand why this administration is
doing that
we know the cause we know the effect we
know where this is going to end we even
know what to do and why aren't we doing
it i cannot come up with a logical
reason why
it makes no sense well your confusion is
our confusion michigan congresswoman
lisa mclean thank you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else